-Our next guest
is an acclaimed author,
whose second novel,
"The Women Could Fly,"
is on sale now
wherever you buy your books.
Please welcome to the show
Megan Giddings, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
-Hi!
-I'm so excited about this,
to have you here.
But I also know
that you were a professor
at University of Minnesota.
-I am.
-So I need to ask,
did you have to cancel
any classes to be here?
-I did. And my
grad students were like...
[ Gasping ]
[ Laughter ]
So...
-So they forgave you for --
I mean,
guess they're probably psyched
to have a day off anyway.
-Oh, they're super psyched.
-Yeah.
-Oh, this worked out great for
everybody, all parties involved.
-We're all happy right now.
-All right, good.
You go back tomorrow, and you
have to teach class tomorrow?
-I don't. I have to just
go to departmental meetings.
So, you can keep me for another
day, so I can miss those, too.
-No worries. I will keep you out
of the departmental meetings.
So, you had your first book,
which was critically acclaimed,
came out right at the beginning
of the pandemic.
-Yes.
-And then, I'm wondering,
did you jump right into writing
the new one,
or did you give yourself
some time?
-I actually jumped right into
the new one in 2018.
So it's one of those things,
like, you never know
if someone's gonna
buy your book or your art,
so you have to have the next
project to sustain you.
You keep working.
-Right, because, of course,
before "Lakewood" came out,
you had a long lead time,
I'm assuming,
between when you finished it
and when it came out.
-Right.
-Instead of taking a break,
you just leaped into this one.
-Yeah, especially with your
first one, you never know.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-So you -- this book covers
fantasy, witchcraft,
race, gender.
It's a lot of different ideas
woven together beautifully.
Where did the idea
first occur to you
to take on themes like these?
-I think it's part of, like,
being alive right now
and being a woman, where --
Because there's a registry
in the book where women,
if you're not married
by the age of 30,
you have a choice.
You either get married
and kind of suck it up,
or you register with the state
as a witch.
Because how dare a woman
not be married at 30.
-Yeah.
-And some of it
also comes from a joke.
Like, I'm from the Midwest,
and there's kind of that vibe --
"If you're not married by 28,
what's wrong with you?"
-Uh-huh?
-"Are you a witch?
Here's a whole book about it."
-There you go.
Sometimes a good Midwestern joke
is a great leaping-off point
for literature.
-Yeah.
It does take place
in an alternate reality
but one that, you know,
certainly doesn't seem
too far removed from the one
we're living through now.
Is it important for you to sort
of separate it a little bit?
Does that let your fiction
breathe a bit more?
-Yeah, I get --
Like, the themes of this book,
it's really hard for me
to just -- if I flat out
wrote the book in this world,
it would just be a rant.
It would be, "Why do we
treat women like this?
Why aren't --
Why aren't we people?"
Oh, my God,
I could be asking that every day
the rest of my life -- "Why
aren't women people to people?"
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
And so I wrote this book,
and it gave me the space
to actually try to get into it.
I wanted to think really deeply
about the things
that made me angry,
but I also wanted room
to, like, play and have fun.
There are parties.
There are witches.
There's joy.
There's jokes.
And I think that space
gave me the room to do that.
-So did you feel
and do you hope both that
it was cathartic for you
to write it?
Do you feel like
it'll be cathartic
for people to read, as well?
Is that one of the things
you lay out
when you try to approach this?
-Especially with this book,
yeah, I wanted people
to feel catharsis.
I want them to feel seen.
In the ending -- I'm trying not
to give away the ending
'cause my publicist would die
if I gave away
the ending right now.
-Yeah, let's not
give away the ending.
-But it's about wanting people
to find community,
to be there for one another.
I wanted there to be hope.
I can't write a book
about feminism and wanting to be
engaged with other people
if we also couldn't want
to make something more
and make the world beautiful.
-That is a very lovely way
to set out in your writing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your parents are not writers,
but your father, a storyteller.
-Yeah, if you ever have
the pleasure of going out
to dinner with my dad,
oh, highly recommend.
-Yes.
-He loves going out to dinner.
But, I mean, whose dad doesn't?
-Whose dad doesn't? Yeah.
-But he really likes looking
around and being like --
telling stories about people,
and he makes up
the weirdest stories.
-He makes them up?
-He makes them up.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And people who have had dinner
with my dad, like,
they'll see me sometimes
doing the same thing
where I'm like,
"Oh, those people
are in a fight,
and I bet it's about this."
And then I keep adding,
they're like,
"You're just like your father."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, sometimes I think
just being around --
I was certainly very lucky.
My father
is a storyteller, as well.
And it's interesting being
around that as a young person.
I do think it just helps you
understand how structure
is important
and how to hold people's
attention is important.
And, obviously, he had
quite an influence on you
because you certainly know how
to put it on the page.
-Oh, thank you.
That's intimidatingly nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, congratulations
on the book.
And thank you to your students
for loaning you to us
for the day.
Congratulations, Megan.
Megan Giddings, everybody.
"The Women Could Fly"
is available now
wherever you buy your books,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."